Area 51 is now so ingrained into popular culture
that it’s virtually synonymous with Aliens;
it’s impossible to mention one without the
other somehow creeping into the conversation,
but why are the two so intrinsically linked?
Why do we automatically picture little green
men any time someone so much as mentions the
words, Area 51?
First it’s important to realize what Area
51 actually is.
For all intents and purposes and according
to every government document ever released,
Area 51 is a “secret” military base where
they test experimental pieces of military
hardware.
For example, experimental jets such as the
SR-71 Blackbird and the Lockheed U-2 Dragon
Lady were tested at the Area 51 base.
The latter of which was actually the first
piece of hardware publicly known to have been
constructed and tested there.
The site Area 51 was built on was supposedly
first chosen due to the incredibly smooth
land found on nearby lake beds, coupled with
the area’s natural inaccessibility.
Both of these features made it perfect for
testing aircraft like the Lockheed U-2 which
required a large area of flat land from which
it could take off and land, while at the same
time required being in an area enemies of
the US couldn’t, at the time, easily lay
their peepers on.
Understandably for a location that deals in
incredibly sensitive military information
that costs billions to produce, the government
has a real hard on for keeping it secret.
However, over the years, this hasn’t exactly
panned out.
For example, on April 19th, 1974, Astronauts
taking part in a Skylab mission accidentally
photographed “the airfield at Groom Lake“-
Groom Lake being an alternative name for Area
51.
The funny part being that this photo wasn’t
taken by the ship the Astronauts were on,
it was taken by one of the Astronauts when
he pointed his camera out of the window.
This is despite the fact that said astronaut
was under specific instructions not to take
pictures of that particular area of Earth;
it’s not currently known whether or not
this event was a mistake made by the astronaut
or a conscious decision on his behalf.
The first known picture of the site to eak
its way into the public domain was taken in
1968 during a U.S. Geological Survey, however,
as far back as 1955 papers have made passing
reference to the facility, referring to it
as a “super-secret atomic energy commission
installation“- they obviously sucked at
naming things back then.
Though the government has always maintained
a rather tightlipped stance on the base, slip
ups have been made in the past.
For example, in this PDF, Area 51 is referred
to, by name, by the, then CIA director Richard
Helms in a secret memo discussing air reconnaissance
of North Vietnam in 1967.
However, for the most part the government
has always either remained coy or simply ignored
the site altogether when referring to it in
official documentation.
As for what it’s like to work at Area 51,
unlike pop-culture would have you believe,
the people who worked there aren’t forbidden
from ever speaking to their family or held
in giant underground bunkers a-la Independence
Day.
Just ask James Noce, who worked in the secret
facility for decades; though James has been
sworn to secrecy, as is to be expected when
you work on highly experimental classified
government projects, he’s free to talk about
his experiences there.
For example, James noted that he was always
paid in cash, whereas others were paid in
cheques from companies they didn’t work
for.
Even more interesting, when a plane from Area
51 crashed once, James was tasked with confiscating
the cameras of a nearby family, who were quickly
rewarded with a fat stack of cash for their
silence.
So why do we think aliens are stored there?
Although the testimonials of people like James,
trusted government and military officials
with decades of experience, do include a number
of telling facts about Area 51, he and the
other people who’ve spoken out about it
have never once alluded to any sort of alien
activity ever occurring there.
But of course, the government would say that;
governments lie all the time about stuff like
this.
So what about Roswell?
Surely that’s when all the rumors started,
right?
Well, not so much.
Though today some conspiracy theorists believe
that the craft that crashed at Roswell was
of Alien origin and that it was or is now
being stored in Area 51, when the incident
first took place, area 51 wasn’t mentioned
in any documentation from that time.
Not to mention the fact that the two sites
are hundreds of miles apart.
If the wreckage was of alien origin and it
was moved, it’s likely the government would
have moved it somewhere closer.
Though the Roswell Daily Record from July
6th, 1947 did feature the words “Flying
Saucer” on its front page, secret government
facilities, and in particular Area 51, were
not mentioned.
As noted above, it would be another 20 years
before Area 51 was even referred to in an
official sense; people back then had no idea
it even existed, meaning that they’d have
been unable to suggest that the wreckage could
have been taken there, even if they did believe
it was of extraterrestrial origin.
In fact, it would appear that the stories
about aliens being held in Area 51 are a rather
recent invention.
It wasn’t until 1989 when the awesomely
named Robert Lazar appeared on a Las Vegas
TV Station under the guise of a government
scientist and stated that Area 51 was just
full of alien technology, that interest in
Area 51 and aliens really started to gain
momentum.
We should mention that almost as soon as Lazar
appeared on TV, every single one of his credentials
was pulled to pieces- no school he claimed
to attend had ever heard of him and the science
behind his theories was soundly debunked.
However, the very first known mention of Area
51 on TV was a full year earlier in 1988 during
the show “UFO Cover-Up?: Live!“, which
oddly enough revolved around the possibility
of the existence of UFOs being covered up.
Just to clarify, Roswell, UFOs, Aliens, little
green men and Area 51 were in no way linked,
as far as popular public opinion was concerned,
until exactly one man went on TV and claimed
that that was
the case.
Science!